upon first hearing that salman khan
would be speaking at castelia during
global week my mind immediately went to
the famous bollywood actor who goes by
the same name
after seconds pause i recognized the
absurdity of the thought and realized
who actually was coming
while the salman khan who joins us today
might not possess flashy dance moves he
is nevertheless a world-renowned movie
star in his own right
salman or sal khan is the founder of the
khan academy a not-for-profit
organization that provides a high
quality education for free to anyone
with internet access
regardless of location social
stratification or age sal has recorded
over a thousand youtube videos available
at khanacademy.org
covering everything from arithmetic and
algebra to calculus physics chemistry
biology and finance
sal personally helps more than 70 000
students a month from all over the world
my family members included
whenever my sisters or i have a problem
the first thing my parents tell us to do
is visit khanacademy.org
sal has successfully helped me study for
the sat help my older sister prepare for
the mcat and help my younger sister
understand difficult chemistry concepts
my mom even frequently visits the
website to learn more about the credit
crisis and to brush up on her
differential calculus
before quitting his day job in september
of 2009 to work on the khan academy
full-time
sal was a senior research analyst at a
bay area investment fund
he had previously held positions in
venture capital engineering and product
management
he received his mba from harvard
business school where he was a student
body president holds a master's degree
in a bachelor of science degree in
electrical engineering and computer
science and has a bachelor of science
degree in mathematics from mit where he
was president of the class of 1998.
what started as a way to help his
younger relatives and family friends
understand course material and do well
in school has turned into a global
sensation touching students from san
francisco switzerland uganda and beyond
he received a 2009 tech award in
education an award that honors
innovators from around the world who
apply technology to benefit humanity
he has also appeared on the rick sanchez
show on cnn to explain the credit crisis
spoken on npr's all things considered
and been interviewed in this recent san
francisco chronicle article
in this article sal was quoted saying
with so little effort on my own part i
can imag i can empower an unlimited
amount of people for all time i can't
imagine a better use of my time
sal's dedication to education i mean
sal's dedication to educating and
enlightening the world free of cost has
inspired and aided millions of people
it is my pleasure to introduce sal khan
but first he will be showing a video
before he comes up
thank you for having me here it's it's
uh it's incredibly exciting on a whole
a set of levels uh i i think the first
thing that makes it really exciting to
be here in particular at castelia uh
many of y'all may know it some of y'all
might not know it uh this was the first
place where i was kind of taken
seriously uh three or four years ago i
was just this guy working at a hedge
fund who had this little software that
barely worked and had a couple of videos
on youtube
and i wanted to get people other than
people who i was maybe related to to
actually use it and uh i i approached uh
ryan i guess you'll call her a miss
sadler she was the the site director for
the peninsula bridge here at castellea
and i i tried to convince her hey why
don't y'all use this at the peninsula
bridge program and she was the first
person who
essentially took took the khan academy
seriously and and uh
the talk i want to give today is really
about uh how things can start small and
and how an individual
with the tools that we have on hand
right now can do uh up uh pretty
far-reaching things and and you really
can't underestimate uh the power of of
those first few people who who believe
in something and and help you take it to
the next level and make you feel uh like
like it's a legitimate project so uh my
my first visit to castelia was a very
positive one and actually played a very
uh crucial role in in what you saw in
that video and actually ryan is now uh
on the board of of we have a two-person
board we're uh oh two-person board and
and i'm essentially the company so it's
a it's a fairly it's a fairly small
organization
which is another theme i want to i want
to touch on uh throughout this
what i want to be more of a conversation
than a lecturer or a talk and and one
thing i want kind of set the ground
rules raise your hand if something comes
to mind or if you don't agree agree with
something or if you
just you know get inspired raise your
hand and i'd be happy to address
something or if i'm i'm i say something
that confuses you
um
the other reason why i'm incredibly
excited about being here is you know one
i i love the theme of global week uh
especially that it's peace it's it's
this notion that is
i think most people are afraid to talk
about things like peace because it's
it's such an audacious uh a goal
you almost feel that if you start
thinking in terms of world peace you're
destined to fail we can get inspired
here today but then when we turn on the
news we're going to see people talk
angrily each other we're gonna uh you
know probably find out about some uh
bombing or whatnot or or in some place
in the world so it's very hard to tackle
this subject i think it's a very
impressive thing to be uh to be tackling
the other reason why it's incredibly
interesting to talk to y'all is
i think the people in this room
are in a unique position and when i say
in a unique position a unique position
as a function of your age and a function
of where we are in history uh that that
i think for the first time i can
legitimately i can legitimately tell
y'all that you are in a position to do
something uh at least as good as the
khan academy and we don't even know
where the khan academy is going to go
but the tools now exist if if if 20
years ago i was someone like me was
giving a talk to uh myself when i was
your when i was your age and they were
to say hey you can you could change the
world i would have i would have rolled
my eyes the best i could have done is uh
maybe had a signature campaign or sent a
letter to a politician or a volunteered
in in my local community which have all
all would have been great but
they wouldn't have reached the threshold
of of changing the world but now i can
sit here or stand here and legitimately
legitimately
tell y'all about my story and hopefully
through my story you'll realize that
you also have the tools at hand to
touch the world in ways that we can't
possibly imagine and it really is a
unique opportunity based on the age and
and kind of your specific life
experience i think y'all are in a better
position to do it than
large corporations with millions of
dollars or uh or large governmental
agencies or or the un or whoever i think
the people in this room using the
technology maybe the type of technology
i use with the khan academy or maybe
other things really have the potential
to do amazing things
what i want to talk about or i kind of
give you the the outline of this of this
talk i'm going to tell you the story of
khan academy but the whole point of
telling you this story is to
put yourself in my shoes as kind of
someone who did who's doing something
that's maybe interesting for them uh
rewarding on a very small scale and and
i want you to kind of uh
take in the experience of how it happens
how it's very organic that it's not like
i just sat down one day and i wrote on
paper i want to educate 80 000 people in
the world or 80 million people in the
world are bossed and if i don't do that
then i'm a big failure i started off
very small with very small goals really
to just
impact a very small set of people all of
whom i happened to be related to and it
slowly uh growed and grow had grown into
something more so i'm going to tell you
the story about khan academy you got a
little bit of a tidbit uh right there
and uh
and and and after that i want to talk a
little bit about what that means for
education and that's another reason why
it's neat to be here this is a school
and uh what could be a more interesting
discussion than where education is going
and i think khan academy might play a
role in it but i think there are just
some trends that are going to happen
whether or not the khan academy you know
if i got hit by a bus god forbid outside
um
regardless of of what happens with there
there are things that that i think are
going to occur and and i think they're
and they're going to occur in the next
10 to 15 years and i think it's a very
interesting discussion to have uh and
then finally uh you know i i've i've
attended when i was young a lot of talks
that inspired me and i wanted to go out
and change the world and start a
revolution and and and and i would be
all inspired and have all this
inspiration and i would go home and i
would kind of you know just twiddle my
thumbs and and not know what to do with
myself and and my energy
and and uh i i had a friend who was kind
of a hardcore athlete and he always told
me never waste inspiration so what what
i want to do uh it's actually a very uh
valuable commodity and so it shouldn't
be wasted so uh what i want to do at the
end of this talk is kind of throw out
ideas i don't want to just tell you my
story and say look you can change the
world and i go home what i want to do is
say look i did this really almost by
chance uh and here's four or five things
that y'all could do and these are really
just to be
seeds in your head of stuff that you
could work on you might think they're
they're horrible ideas but hopefully at
least get your your your juices flowing
on on ways that that you might be able
to impact the world
so so to start off uh you you got a
little tidbit right there uh i four
five years ago i was a newly minted mba
i was working at a hedge fund it's kind
of a bad word now but not all hedge
funds are are are evil uh
many are though
but um
i was
my portfolio manager who's a vegetarian
and he he if we if we made money off of
off of an egg company he would donate
his profits to fight uh abuse of
chickens i i have not made this up so we
were we were a a more ethical hedge fund
but um
i was a newly minted mba working at a as
a hedge fund analyst in boston i i had
just gotten married in new jersey uh i
had some family that wanted to visit me
in boston with my aunt and uncle and
their children uh nadia armand armand
and ali nadia was the oldest she was 12
years old at the time uh they visited me
just to see boston
take in the sights and it was exciting
for me because it was the first time
that i really got to spend time with my
cousins when i was in new orleans they
were from new orleans i grew up in new
orleans uh
when i was there before high school they
were toddlers and i never had really a
serious discussion with them or i never
really was able to bond with them but
now when they visited me in boston for
the first time i was really able to
connect with them and and navia
especially impressed me and i think this
the story is especially interesting
talking to many of y'all because when i
look out in the audience i see
a lot of nadias i see a lot of uh uh uh
bright motivated young women who you
know in nadia's case as soon as i spent
a couple of hours with her uh talking to
her about life and what she wanted to do
and politics and philosophy and i would
give her brain teasers she was just
ultra sharp you know here was i i was i
thought i was this a reasonably
sophisticated 25 or 26 year old and i i
literally could talk to her as an equal
and sometimes i felt like i was a little
bit out of my league uh so so she was
you know i was just wildly impressed by
her so you can imagine i think it's
you've probably experienced this a
little bit with your own parents
but when you have a uh when you have a
when you meet a young person who you're
very impressed by who you think has a
lot of potential you have this natural
inclination to want that to have them
follow in your footsteps you know
everyone thinks that what they do is uh
the best possible thing so uh
while we were touring around boston we
visited mit uh and you know when i was
visiting mit i told nadia and the whole
family was there i said nadia you know i
know you probably you know there's
probably all these stereotypes in your
head that make you not think that you
want to go to this school and uh you
know it has this heart but but i
generally think based on interacting
with you uh you're creative you you show
this uh this analytical ability you know
i really think i'm just going to put the
seed in your head you don't have to do
it no pressure but but i really think
this would be a good place for you to
think about coming to and then maybe
you'd want to be an engineer or you know
become an engineer and then one day work
at a hedge fund but a good hedge fund
and uh uh
and and and
and if any of y'all are interested in
that career path talk to me afterwards
we can uh i'll be your personal
counselor but um
uh uh you know she she kind of i think
did what a lot of y'all would do when
when your mom or dad tries to get you
into the family business uh tries to she
they kind of she rolled her eyes a
little bit and said oh no thanks but you
know i you know i don't know about it
you know i was kind of thinking of
becoming a journalist or something so uh
you know i don't know if i really got a
lot of traction but when i said that at
the same time that i was uh talking to
nadia about possibly coming to mit uh i
i saw my aunt and uncle kind of give
each other a look like a look like you
know what is what's sal talking about
you know asking ar nadia to go to mit
and i didn't know how to interpret that
look i thought you know maybe it's uh
another one of these stereotypical
things about women uh in in and
technical fields and engineering or
whatever or maybe it was something
deeper who knows or maybe it was just
you know my aunt was mad at my uncle for
some other random
but but i didn't know uh but it kind of
it caught my eye and so uh the next
morning before everyone else had woken
up uh uh my aunt najru dante had come to
uh we were just hanging out everyone
else was still asleep and she she said
sal you know i can't tell you how great
it is that uh you're a bit of a role
model for for my children uh they really
look up to you they're enjoying this
trip tremendously you can't i can't tell
you how much it's affecting them they're
getting inspired to do things they all
want to come to boston to go to college
and they love the area
but but she said you know the one thing
that uh you probably don't know and it's
kind of concerning us and it's been an
issue in the family is that uh nadia is
actually having a lot of difficulty uh
in in math right now and she was
actually placed into
the slower track in her uh as she goes
into seventh grade they didn't place her
into the track that would allow her to
take algebra in eighth grade and then
progress on that that track i think many
of y'all are on that allows you to kind
of a college preparatory track where you
take calculus in in high school what not
uh so for me this was this was obviously
surprising i just told you uh how
impressive nadia was sometimes when i
would speak to her i felt like uh i i
was i was speaking to someone out of my
own league uh and and for me to think
that in sixth grade uh there there was
something that was tripping her up uh
you know i i i i it was it was almost
hard for me to believe so when when
nadia woke up uh i i pulled her i was
like hey you know your mom says you're
having an issue with something in
mathematics um you know what what do you
think is the situation she says i just
don't get units she just doesn't get you
know
kilograms to uh
kilograms to milligrams or pounds to
ounces or uh you know and and it does i
mean it gives all of us a little bit of
a headache but she just she just didn't
get it and she says i just have when i
see those problems i just my brain just
shuts down and i just think it's beyond
me
and and so i told her i said nadia um
let's let's do a deal
you're you're here for actually another
it was i think it was like the last day
of their visit so you're gonna leave
tomorrow i'll go back to new orleans but
i am 100 000 convinced that you are
well capable of learning units and i
actually suspect that you're capable of
learning things far deeper than units uh
but it's just it's it's just my
suspicion so why don't we do some type
of remote tutoring uh what we could you
know you go back to new orleans we'll
get on a speaker phone and uh we'll get
some pen tablets maybe and we'll find
something that we can where we write uh
we can both see what we're each writing
and and and and she agreed i think she
was
one kind of excited about this idea of
of having someone interested in in in
her directly and giving her that
one-on-one attention and uh uh
and kind of someone to be able to
connect with i was i'm i was kind of
like her older brother uh but on the
other level i think she was a little bit
daunted by the idea it kind of was a
little extra pressure above and beyond
what you already have from school and
and being a a middle school uh uh a
young woman which i'm a lot of pressures
that y'all are probably facing on some
dimension right now it's it's actually
very strange to be talking to you all
about nadia because i keep realizing
that a lot of y'all are nadia or in some
way are are uh you know have elements
that are similar to her so it adds a
whole new level to this conversation uh
but
she agreed uh within a week we both had
our pen tablets uh she was in new
orleans i was in i was in boston and i
would come home from work right after
the market closed i i would call her up
she would be done with all of her i
think she was on the basketball team at
the time and we would start doing these
sessions and and
and i've got to tell you
the first week
was
was painful
it
the the the tone of the conversation
when when when we were just speaking as
as friends or as as relations uh it was
it was a dynamic conversation really
intelligent really engaging really
fast-paced
but as soon as we
entered this domain of units which was
our first kind of subject subject to
tackle as soon as we entered that domain
i felt like she just shut down it was
you know i would ask her a question i
you know i don't you know how many how
many kilometers would that be
and there would be this this long pause
and i i didn't know if i lost lost her
on the line if something happened with
our internet connection uh and then
her answers were always in the form of a
question there were always like a
hundred
ten
uh you know and
and and i had no idea i said nadia are
you guessing are you uh you know do you
do if
i i it was just very difficult i can
imagine if it was painful for me it was
probably
ten times as painful for her because
above and beyond this being a subject
that she was struggling with and we all
have had that feeling of struggling with
something uh this was uh you know she
was working with her her cousin who she
probably wanted to impress because he
was already impressed by her uh he
already believes in her and she probably
felt all this anxiety of being judged
and and whatnot
so literally after a week of this i
started questioning whether
this made sense whether i had
done more harm than good
whether you know she was already having
difficulty and i i was getting pretty
close to to giving up on her uh just
because it felt like we had made no
headway in in a week after five sessions
uh so i kind of made a last-ditch effort
the next conversation i had with her i
said nadia
i know you're smart i know it by based
on interacting with you and and we also
share a certain amount of dna so
that that by itself would was proof
enough i am not judging you i am not
judging you in no way shape or form
you need to view me as a resource purely
as a resource there's nothing that you
can ask me that in any way will make me
think less of you in fact the more
questions you ask will make me think
more of you and i need you to to be
completely honest when you don't
understand something and when i ask a
question
either say i do not know the answer to
that question sal please explain it or
answer in the affirmative don't say 10
say 10 or say i do not understand just
be very be a little bit more engaging
and it worked it over the next week
because she started giving me more
information about what it exactly was in
her brain that was having trouble with
units i was able to to hone in a little
bit better and address those those small
points of confusion that she had when do
you multiply when do you divide i i
think that's the confusion many people
have with concepts of of units you're
always multiplying and dividing by
different things uh
but she got it and once she got it it
was it was fascinating because
something clicked in her head she not
only she go from thinking that it was
this huge intractable impossible thing
to do she went to thinking that it was
easy and she thought it was so easy and
so intuitive that she was almost angry
about it she was angry that something
that she now found three weeks later to
be intuitive and easy and natural she
was angry that this was
potentially derailing her her
her career or derailing her
self-impression or or not allowing her
to proceed with her other friends into
the into the the normal track uh math
class uh and i want to take a side here
from nadia's story because i think that
experience i don't know if any of y'all
have experienced it yet hopefully you
will i've experienced it multiple times
in my life where you have this
intractable problem that you're almost
ready to give up that you just think
your brain is not built for this type of
problem when you when you're faced with
something like that most people give up
and the rest of their life they kind of
think that i'm not meant to do algebra
i'm not meant to do calculus i'm not
meant to do physics or you know i used
to know people you know on the other
side i'm not meant to be a writer i'm
not meant to uh uh you know i i i i'm a
slow reader whatever it might be we we
all faces and most people tend to give
up but that experience of facing it once
in your life
and then overcoming it and overcoming it
in a way that you realize that it's
actually an easy thing that's
tremendously powerful and i think is
tremendously transformational and i
encourage y'all to try to have those
type of experiences to try to really
engage with things that you you find
intractable right now because i
guarantee you at the age that you're at
right now if you discover that it really
is not so intractable and if you really
can overcome uh that hurdle the rest of
your life you won't really find anything
uh to be impossible you're gonna realize
that you just have to engage and be
aggressive and and find the right
resources with enough energy and and
things will work out but nadia you know
make a long story short she she just
progressed tremendously
from then on once she figured out that
if she just uh engaged enough that she
would she would be able to to understand
the concepts we just keep proceeding
forward and after a month or two i said
nadia you know the stuff we're covering
now this is stuff that not only you
would normally expect of a of a smart uh
or an advanced seventh or eighth grader
this is material that you would expect
of a advanced ninth or tenth grader and
from then on and since then this was in
this was in 2004 2005 that we started i
mean nadia just turned into a rock star
and she uh ended up uh taking uh uh uh
or maybe a mathlete uh but but she she
she she she ended up to take you know
and not i i don't want to give the
impression that i think this is the
measure of a person of what math classes
they take in what year and all of that
but i just want to i want to give you a
very tangible example of someone who i
saw firsthand who went from someone who
was ready to give up on mathematics at
the age of 12 or 13
to someone who took calculus when she
was a freshman in high school uh who who
ended up
having to go to the university of new
orleans when she was a sophomore because
they had run out of math classes at our
high school and uh but
at the same time at the same time she
now still wants to be a writer so this
isn't something where she she's actually
going to go to sarah lawrence and she
wants to be a writer and and and you
know god bless her i don't you know she
she didn't want to be an engineer and a
hedge fund manager but she
but but but this is this is the
important thing she didn't become a
writer i think in a lot of asian and a
lot of uh you know
my family is originally from south asia
in our culture there's kind of this
notion of oh they're becoming a writer
because they couldn't be an engineer or
because they couldn't be a doctor but in
nadi's example she can say oh yeah well
i could have been one but i'm deciding
to do this and i think it's it's super
important uh for for people to have that
option for her to know that she made the
decision to to uh to
be a writer as opposed to being forced
into it because when she was in sixth
grade she had given up on mathematics so
nadia's you know after nadia story i got
to tell you that was
probably the most rewarding experience
in my life up to date you know you can
imagine i was this a guy working at a
hedge fund it's an intellectually
stimulating job uh but it's a it's a job
where it's hard to answer the question
of
what did you do for humanity today you
know i i actually used to have this uh
rationalization as well you know in a
communist system you have these central
planners who like to allocate the
capital but in the capitalist system you
need people participating in the market
to make sure that prices are set
efficiently and only when prices are set
efficiently can capital be allocated
efficiently and because of that people
will be better off that was my
rationalization for for working at a
hedge fund but as you can imagine this
is kind of a convoluted argument and it
would always make my uh wife roll her
eyes
so
so you know to be able to come home and
and touch someone in a meaningful way
someone who i was related to uh
and and feel that i was impacting her
life's trajectory uh tremendously
satisfying and i decided i wanted to
keep going so i started with her younger
brothers armand and ali then i started
with
some other cousins other family friends
and this is really now we're going into
uh
2005 early 2006. i had this cohort of
about 15 or 20 students that i would do
this i tried to replicate the the nadia
model i would i would get on a
conference call and we would use yahoo
doodle to write with each other and to
see what we're doing but as you can
imagine because it became very hard to
scale up
you know i had the luxury with nadia
being of having this one-on-one
interaction
even when i started getting having small
groups of two or three students at the
same time it just became completely
different hard to scale but i thought
really hard how can i that that same
thing that i did with nadia how can i
somehow
uh kind of scale it up how can i print
out more versions of of myself or or so
that other people can interact in the
same way
and so one thing i did is i started
writing some software and it was fun for
me again because i had given up my my
computer science part of my brain to go
work in in finance so it was just a fun
project for me but the whole goal of the
software was to be able to hone in on
that weak point to automate that process
that i had that question and answer
process i had with nadia where i was
able to realize oh she just doesn't get
uh you know this this more basic concept
and that's why she was having trouble
with the idea of units so i wrote a
little bit of software like that and i
put a little database behind it so that
i could keep track what the students
were working on
uh and and the student and my my cousins
they liked it you know they enjoyed the
fact that it was generating problems for
them and they could practice uh but the
harder problem and this is what really
directly lead led to where the khan
academy is now is
how do we schedule time with each other
how do we how do we how can i teach all
of these students i only had 20 right
now but it was already getting becoming
too much for me in a way that uh they
could learn at their own pace uh they
they could uh they could learn at their
own time and so that's where the idea
and it really wasn't my idea i have to
give credit to a a friend of mine who
who said hey you know why don't you just
put some stuff up on youtube and you
know i i have to say my own pride right
when he said i was like no no my
software is enough you know youtube
videos that's you know my software is so
good it gives people hints and it's you
know it's web-based and it has a
database and you should see the database
and it's you know this
but
after i kind of after i kind of got over
the fact that i didn't think of the idea
um i said well
maybe i'll try uh some of these youtube
videos and the very first youtube video
i did was least common multiple so if
you if you watch that video it's by far
the most um rough video and it's you
know hopefully it'll be a part of
history one day but uh i i i i made that
video and uh
and and because my cousins and family
friends who needed to learn the least
common multiples they actually said they
really liked it because uh
actually one of them
told me and this was a bit of a
backhanded compliment i didn't know what
to think of it they said oh i like you
better on youtube
that's this this uh
and and it's actually funny
he was the first person to say it but i
got that feedback over and over again
and i think the core issue of why i'm
better on youtube is one there isn't the
stress
when you have this interaction with with
a tutor or a teacher of hey do you get
this
and and you're kind of like oh gee he's
looking at me and you know
i'm sorry you were just sitting right
there so you had to uh
but but it's hard to think when someone
is waiting for you to to process
something that you're just learning to
get get your hands around and maybe i
said something that you don't understand
but you don't want to ask me because
it's a basic concept and you want me to
think that you're a smart individual but
this is something that you really should
have mastered probably in fourth or
fifth grade and you're in ninth grade
now and if you tell me that you really
don't know how you know dividing
decimals is still kind of this little
gray area and if if dividing decimals
actually is you're not alone i've i
actually want to go to a mall one day
and just see how many adults but anyway
that's a that's a whole that's a whole i
can't tell you how many letters i get
from
all sorts of people all walks of life
the dividing decimals is kind of the one
thing that no one wants to admit that
they kind of forgot how to do but it's a
it's it's a huge need inside but anyway
that that's a i go on tangents um
but but uh i was talking about why i'm
better on youtube is that you can pause
me you can repeat me you can you can uh
if i say something you don't understand
you can you can go go to wikipedia go to
some other site or go to one of my other
videos and get that that part of that
concept filled in and there's no stress
you're doing it at your own time i
actually got a uh i i got a letter from
a college student once and and he he
wrote me
he's like i can't tell you how valuable
this is he said i actually have a very
good calculus professor but our class is
at seven in the morning on a monday and
when i'm there there's this cute girl
who sits two rows in front of me
i all i have to all i can think about
all day throughout the entire class is
whether i'm going to have the guts to
walk up to her after class and ask her
out and i think about whether i want to
write memoirs about what i did last
weekend and um and by the time all those
thoughts go on he's completely missed
the calculus class and it's seven in the
morning and then he goes home and he
watches the youtube videos and so i mean
his story is it
it's actually very realistic it's what
happens all the time and in the in the
in the model that's kind of in the
standard model you're
you
you you are learning you and the teacher
in a room that's dictated by some
schedule it has to be based on logistics
it's no one's fault really
but you know the t yeah if i had to
teach you a concept every day at seven
in the morning sometimes i'm not going
to be on my a game right i'm not going
to be super passionate about it because
teachers are people too and and
sometimes it's hard to but but um
but but
it's hard for the teacher sometimes and
it's especially hard for the student to
engage especially if there's some other
thing that they they're thinking about
or other sleepy or uh that they've um
there's some core concept that they
missed in the last class so this idea of
being able to get something on demand is
tremendously useful and once i got that
feedback from my cousins and and family
friends i i made more videos and and i
at first i put the videos up and you
know obviously i expected about 10 or 20
people to watch them but slowly
people that weren't related to me or who
didn't know me personally started
watching them
and that kept growing uh you know i got
excited i don't know how many of y'all
have seen the movie julia and julia
have you okay yeah i mean when i was
watching that movie i felt like this is
like i mean on some
metaphysical level i felt some kind it
was actually i didn't want to watch it i
thought it was about cooking or
something i didn't realize it was about
someone who started a blog that became
very popular and but but that experience
she had where she kind of keeps pressing
refresh
and she's amazed that someone other than
her mother actually read her blog that
was me that was me uh four years ago i
would put a video up and and and and i
would keep refreshing it
and and i still do this i'm not as
secure as i might appear to be
i i i keep refreshing it until i get
some feedback and and uh something you
know either the you little youtube
people rate it if they give five stars i
i'm very sensitive if someone even gives
four stars i kind of question whether
i'm doing the right thing and whether i
should go back to finance and what what
not i've uh it's it's a very uh
emotionally trying experience but i keep
refreshing
and and and i wait to see some positive
feedback and eventually someone will
just say thank you and as soon as they
say thank you you're like oh good good
this was somewhat useful to somebody
i'll record the next video now so so i i
can't tell you um
how valuable that that notion is but
more and more people uh kept watching it
uh over the course of the next few years
uh you know it grew roughly 20 a month
and if you know you're familiar with the
compounding of growth that's actually a
very fast rate you're going several fold
every year and and now as as i was
thankfully introduced uh it's reaching
actually on the order of about a hundred
thousand students now a month uh and uh
40 000 video views a day and what's
really exciting about it is that's just
a small sliver of people who just happen
to have found out about it through word
of mouth or through friends and family
or through some uh
through the blogosphere someone might
have written about it's a very small
sliver of i think the people who could
benefit from something like this and on
top of you know the the the hundred
thousand people i mean you know
it's still mind-boggling to me when i
say these numbers you know here i am
just sitting in my pajamas recording
youtube videos all day and while i'm
having breakfast or uh at work i didn't
quit my job until three months ago while
i was at work or sleeping or somebody
around the world is learning from me
they're they're they're being empowered
on some level and this is kind of you
know this is what i think is kind of the
most important ingredient in in in the
theme of peace of just that individual
empowerment and it's happening with no
effort on my part no cost to me
nothing i'm doing but that person is
getting empowered it's like it's like a
perpetual motion machine it's like it's
like you're making a gold out of uh out
of lead it's it's it's it's like
creating something out of nothing and it
and and that idea to me is still
mind-boggling and it doesn't have to be
a hundred thousand people just the idea
that even one person it's happening for
is mind-boggling to me and then when you
throw numbers like hundred thousand or
you know we've had nine million video i
i have trouble even even completely uh
understanding what that means but it
just it just amazes me but it and and
you know out of the blue and once again
i i want this narrative to kind of be to
show you how organically things can
happen uh out of the blue i got a a
letter from somebody
who who distributes computers in uganda
and said we distribute these computers
and we don't have any internet access
and but we love the khan academy videos
we've seen some of the students interact
with them they love them how can we get
these videos to these students in uganda
i had no idea you know i was just
recording youtube videos so so the the
next very next email this is why you
know i'm not the the most religious
person on the planet but you know
sometimes things happen in certain ways
or using g you know some there's some
aliens or something controlling
what what's happening to me uh but but
the very next email was this group of
volunteers from cisco systems that that
said hey we like your videos we kind of
view them as you know a k-12 a school in
a box for for children who don't have
access to good teachers uh so why don't
we uh uh is there can we download your
videos and put them on hard disks and
distribute it to other groups i said
well yeah not only can you do that but
uh there's this other guy who just
emailed me literally four minutes ago
why don't you send him a hard drive
and literally in about four minutes of
forwarding emails i got a i got a letter
from the group that's called
uconnect.org in
uganda a week later saying we have the
hard drive from that group at cisco
world possible literally it just
happened with a couple of email forwards
and the kids in uganda love it and then
all of a sudden i did nothing i did
absolutely nothing i forwarded a couple
of emails between people and it was just
this we're at this period in in and and
i want this you know this is my story
but but i want this you to think about
this could kind of be your story as well
because
we're at this point in where technology
is and how society is getting
interconnected where people are just
waking up and they're realizing gee you
know that's there that's there if we put
those things two things together and
take it over there that's free gold
that's we're turning lead into gold with
no cost for anybody and and and i think
khan academy is just one small sliver of
what could uh could be done i think
there's a whole set of dimensions and i
think the people in this room probably
could think of you've been immersed in
this from from you know you're immersed
in it right now in this in you know
whatever you want to call it web 2.0 you
understand this it makes sense to you
and and i think uh there's no reason why
everyone in this room couldn't uh do
something similar although i i don't
know in what form it might take we can
talk more about that uh later
but you know so so kaneka that's kind of
the the organic story about how it
happened how i ended up here you know
somewhere in there i showed up uh with
the software and the videos at ryan's
office and i said uh you know can you
use this for the peninsula bridge and
she's like you know at first she's like
it doesn't work on max because we only
have max and if it doesn't work on matt
actually it didn't work on max at the
time but i said well i think it does but
it's it's uh it's a it's a little part
of salesmanship you have to learn early
on to
well anyway
if you think it's not necessarily a lot
but anyway
yeah
uh but we got it working on max and it
was used at peninsula bridge and
actually that was a tremendously
powerful experience there because
at peninsular bridge we saw that pattern
that i saw with nadu there was actually
there's a chart actually i'll show the
chart well i won't show the chart it's
it's small and all of that but the big
takeaway this this kind of leads into
where education is going
right now
when you learn there's just snapshots
right you get assessed at certain points
in your life and those assessments tell
you whether you're good at math or bad
at math or good at reading or bad at
reading and what we saw when we dealt
with the the students at peninsula
bridge who had a whole uh
a spectrum of backgrounds is that when
you started everyone at one plus one
equals two and then let them progress at
their own pace that there were some
students who had just very very basic
deficiencies they just didn't understand
uh negative numbers or they didn't
understand
a borrowing or i guess it's called
regrouping or however you want to call
it they didn't understand subtracting
numbers and in a traditional learning
model when those students get to algebra
these were i think they were rising 7th
or 8th graders
you could have the best algebra teacher
on the planet and you can be the
smartest student on the planet but if
you are having a basic weakness in
negative numbers or subtracting numbers
that conversation you're just going to
be talking past each other and the
teacher's going to get frustrated the
teacher's going to wonder what they're
doing wrong and the student's going to
wonder you know why why do i not get
this when everyone else has guessed this
and the main issue is this core weakness
very early on in their careers that
can't be addressed
the way that the current system is
structured and once again it's no one's
fault it's all a byproduct of of being
able to get people in a room and being
able to have one teacher teach
10 20 30 students but the exciting thing
is over the next 10 15 years through
technology i think some of this can be
addressed when i talk about technology i
don't want to give any anyone the
impression that i kind of want to take
the human out of the equation i think
it's the opposite i think what
technology will allow us to do
is
let the human be the human and and and
the technology will take off it will
take away all the minutiae take i'll
take away all of the things that it's
hard for a teacher to do you know
whether it's a writing exams or grading
papers or or um or trying to assess what
the core weak points are in a student
let the technology do that and then let
the teacher go in and be that mentor be
what i was with nadia uh uh kind of
guide them and and really focus and give
them that instruction that that the
videos and the software uh could never
do so i wanna i wanna make that very
clear because some types you know people
see me i have this uh background about a
potentially robot you know i'm the kind
of guy that people think wants robots to
take over the world and and whatever
that's not nothing can be uh further
from the truth uh one question i get a
lot from um
especially when i started off
was uh people asking
well you know one why are you doing this
and and two you know how do you know uh
that this is is working and i have a lot
of data and i could show you the data
but that would bore you but the single
biggest thing that i think motivated has
been motivating me and and i think that
is proof that it's working is some of
the letters i get and i'll just i'll
just read a couple letters and i feel a
little bit awkward about doing this
because it's kind of self-praise and and
my my wife has made me very
conscientious about self-praise
um
but but i want you to i want i want it i
want it to be i want you to think of how
i would feel reading this working at a
hedge fund where all day you know the
best thing i could get is maybe a couple
extra dollars bonus from my boss you
know he never uh
writes me a letter like this but let me
let me read i mean these are
mind-blowing and the point here is i
want you to realize that internet and
web technologies can touch people in
tremendously tremendously meaningful
ways
so hello sal my 12 year old son has
autism and has had terrible time with
math we've tried everything viewed
everything bought everything well we
stumbled across your video on decimals
and it got through
then we went on to dreaded fractions
again he got it we couldn't believe it
he was so excited it's your soothing
voice and calm manner
coupled
coupled with an easygoing explanation
and examples i can't say thank you
enough you are a hero once again i i
didn't jump into a burning building i
didn't save you know someone's kitten
from a rooftop i'm not you know gi joe
this person
while i'm while i'm sleeping or are
eating lunch or at work analyzing uh
financial statements for for at my hedge
fund this person is calling me a hero
with no extra effort online here's
another one i'll just read this one i
mean this this one is it's almost
when i read this this is pretty much
what sealed the deal for me to for me to
quit my job i got this in august of 09
and i quit uh two weeks later just
because i realized if people are being
touched in this way i i've got to be
able to figure out a way to do this
full-time
mr khan no teacher has done me any good
this may sound harsh but i mean it quite
literally i was force-fed medication to
keep me from talking and chastised for
not speaking out when called on where i
am from blacks are not welcomed with
open arms into schools my mother and her
sisters had to go to a small shack two
hours from home when they went to school
about five years ago
my family collected enough money to move
from where i was born so that i could
have a chance at an education and living
a real life but without a real mastery
of elementary math i was slow to
progress i am now in college and
learning more than i ever have in my
life but an inadequate math background
has been holding me back i found the
khan academy in june of 2009. so this is
literally six months ago
right after i had completed math 141 a
college algebra course i spent the
entire summer on your youtube page and i
just wanted to thank you for everything
you're doing and this is once again you
are a godsend i mean i i don't know what
to even say i mean that makes me feel
awkward that's
that's
last week
last week i tested for a math placement
exam and i am now an honors math 200.
now this is the keyboard no question was
answered incorrectly i mean this goes
from someone who had
it it's mind-blowing my placement test
holder was so impressed by the breadth
of my knowledge of math that he said i
should be in linear algebra mr khan i
can say with any doubt you've changed my
life and the lives of everyone in my
family i i just i mean this this is
happening
through the internet this is something
you can reach people it doesn't have to
be through education i think any time
that you interact with people and they
can see humanity
you are fostering world peace
and i i want to finish off with just
things that you can do i mean i promised
i would throw out some tangible ideas i
mean the first thing is you all could do
exactly what i did teach things even
teach mathematics
different types of teachers are you are
people respond to different types of
instruction all of the time your take on
things might connect with people in new
and innovative ways teach teach english
there can't there's no better way to
empower people in the developing world
to participate in the global economy
than learning english and that's
something i think everyone in this room
could do
set up skype buddies so that you can
start interacting with people across the
world or even better try to get people
in iran and israel to interact with each
other or pakistan and india to interact
with each other that is very tangible
world peace and that's something that
you can go home right now and do from
your living room uh you could uh you
know one idea that i threw out
record videos where little screen plays
three minute videos and i think everyone
in this room collectively could get the
job done in a couple of weeks where
y'all just
use sat words you use them flagrantly
and and you you uh
and and the the idea being and you know
and it would be cheesy and it would be
silly and it would be kind of ridiculous
but i guarantee one through the process
of making those videos uh you're going
to do a lot better on the sat verbal
section but but even more importantly
it'll be used by your peers probably
future young women at castelia and even
more interestingly i guarantee you if
they are smart and funny but but rough
and and and genuine and human
that people all over the world very
likely will start to use it and you'll
be empowering them to to to to get to to
perform well on on things that that that
really do matter uh so so hopefully um
you know through my story and and
you you do appreciate this idea that
y'all are in a position to go home right
now without millions of dollars without
government governmental support to start
something that has the potential over
the next five to ten years to touch
millions of people and even if it
doesn't touch millions of people you
should if it just touches your direct
community and your direct friends and
family that alone
makes it worthwhile so i thank you all
very much for for having me and and i'm
open any questions
if anyone has any questions or
oh yeah
do you think that you'll ever do
anything like history lessons or english
lessons
yes
i i that's actually on my to-do list on
my whiteboard right i want history
lessons uh one just because i think
there's this huge gap between the news
and what goes on in history class right
now where you know the news is these
30-second sound bites in history class
you know you start off with mohenjo-daro
and harappa and if you're lucky you
might get to like you know world war ii
but there's this huge gap between that
and i i don't think that happens here at
castle but you know i never got beyond
world war ii in my history so but that
leaves this huge gap and why is the
world the way it is right now so
actually i would like to do a little ten
minute uh you know uh ten minutes on uh
israel and palestine conflict ten
minutes on india obviously these are
very touchy issues and you know i i'm
gonna have a lot of caveats up there
actually have a whole set of videos on
on intelligent design and evolution i
have i keep asterisks you know i this
isn't you know i don't want to skew your
opinion well anyway
but but i i do i do intend to do that i
do want to do grammar um i want to do
everything but you know i i think all of
y'all should kind of join in it's
yeah
yeah yeah
how do you know so much on all these
subjects
my my wife would be rolling her eyes
right now because she's
wait well um well there's a there's
there's a small set of things that i do
know innately you know based on my
background i was a math elite in high
school on on on some level uh but but
but other things other things uh like
like say biology you know i took the
courses i did you know i got an a in the
course but that doesn't mean i'm like an
expert on biology uh what i do is and
this is what's really fun for me what
the other aspect that really motivates
me is i get to
sit and learn things the way i never
learned them before so when for example
i did some videos on entropy a few weeks
ago and entropy was something that i
never understood properly in high school
i mean i could kind of write the right
words on the exam but i never quite
understood what it meant so i literally
pondered it for two weeks and i would
call up my thermodynamics professor
friends at stanford and mit is like
let's have a conversation about entropy
and we would do that and then over the
course of time over two weeks i was like
okay now i get entropy and i would i
would make the videos on them so a lot
of it is it's a learning process for me
and that's what makes it so much fun
oh sorry sorry and just so you all know
that the question was how do i know so
much that was the uh
oh
like what was that yeah was that
transition oh yeah well you're one of
the few people to refer to it as a brand
but that's exciting so the question is
when did when did the youtube videos
become the brand uh a khan academy um i
i think
i i was at a birthday party for a friend
and he was the first person to say you
know what you're doing with your cousins
this is actually something that could be
generally useful you should kind of do
something with it make it into some type
of an organization the khan academy is
is a non-for-profit organization but
when he told me that that was the first
time that i i thought about uh the idea
wow you know this could be a virtual
school this could be type of so uh since
it's a non-profit organization i was
like well you know gee there's no
ownership how do i make sure they don't
fire me one day and i said well let me
name it after myself
yeah so the question was how did i how
did i develop a curriculum and i
actually get a lot of i've actually
talked to the state of california that's
the first question they asked where's
the curriculum come from
the initially started very organically
it was kind of math and science as i had
known it with the theory being if
someone if i'm able to convey that
understanding in those connections that
that's a good understanding
youtube had 10 minute time limits on me
initially and that was super fortuitous
because it forced me to 10 minutes and
what that allowed me to do is make the
concepts very very granular and short so
uh you know like miami-dade county has
actually used them for teacher training
so it can it's very easy to map it to
almost any curriculum now because the
videos uh just cover kind of one small
concept at a time so you could say oh
the standard 2.3.2 in the california
standards oh that's these four videos so
i i don't have any but but some of the
things i am doing now i do look at
textbooks i do uh i do look at what the
ap curriculum the standards are so i do
try to make it so it's useful for for
you know tests that people are gonna
have to take
oh
up there in the black
so that's excellent so the question is
how do i make it available uh to people
who don't speak english um english is
the only language i i speak well
i i can laughably speak
hindi urdu and bengali but that wouldn't
do
the job so that's an excellent question
people have come out of the woodworks
this is another thing i actually forgot
to talk about people have come out of
the woodworks over the last three months
really to start translating the videos
and because in the videos you don't see
my face the translations work really
well they look like they were natively
spoken there's actually a chemistry
teacher in uruguay who has started
translating the chemistry videos they
have and he set up a khan academy and
espanol channel so it's just happening
organically they're they're translating
translators are doing it into polish
german
it's and once again i'm not doing
nothing all i'm just saying is go ahead
and people are translating it
i i i am no longer directly interfering
i mean i i do so the question is do i
find that there's still some children
who need uh personal tuition kind of
what i was used to doing with nadia and
and her brothers i'm not i still call
them up and kind of check in on on them
but i haven't been doing that that
one-on-one session with them anymore i
mean they're all in high school now and
they've kind of i think gotten over
their hurdles but i'm not but i think i
don't want to make it sound like this
solves all the problems i think this
gets a lot of problems out of the way so
that the the personal time with a
teacher or tutor can be a lot more
productive so i think i'm sure there are
people who can always benefit from from
that personal uh instruction
yeah right here
right here in front right yeah you yeah
yeah so the question is when i make the
videos how do i decide what concept i i
cover next and some of it i get emails
all the time i take requests and i'm
telling this to all of y'all if y'all
have a particularly uh hairy uh a
problem uh that i haven't
send me send it to me seriously and i
literally i'll put your email up and
i'll do a video on it and and if it's
and it'll be up there uh but uh so i do
take requests but a lot of it is is kind
of my mood i mean this this is uh i'm
doing this almost out of uh you know
it's fun for me so i i do what's
interesting where i think a lot of
people would find value from it but uh
the simple answer is what i feel like
teaching is what i teach which is a huge
luxury i think
yeah so so where i see it going and you
know
i could give i could talk for another
hour
so right now there's the videos i intend
to keep making videos several hundred a
year i really want to cover everything
uh oh the question was where do i see
khan academy going over the next five
ten years uh so i'm gonna keep making
videos the software piece i want to
build out i'm talking to some
philanthropic groups about potentially
being able to hire a small team of
engineers to build out the software so
can people can practice and we can get
data on what works and what doesn't work
and then and this is kind of this
actually ties into world peace what i
want to do is overlay that with
community where
people are using the videos people are
using the software but if they still
don't get it the the site knows what
they're having difficulty with and it
can match them up with someone else you
are a ninth grader in tehran you need
trouble you have trouble with systems of
equations there's a
a brilliant teacher who's a a
10th grader in tel aviv and we'll
connect the two of you and you all will
have a session and y'all will talk about
mathematics and
respect each other and do well and as
you can imagine over time that can that
can foster a whole set of other things
and actually i'm talking to these
philanthropic groups because there's
potential of going into rural villages
where you you can't find algebra
teachers where
students even if you build them the best
school on the planet and you give them
the teachers they're not going to show
up because they have to help out their
families
during the harvest or or work or
whatever else so
the idea is really kind of have a school
in the box where kids can learn on their
own time and then the philanthropic
group can actually take a step back and
and the data comes back to them and see
what the kids in the villages are
actually doing so i i kind of envisioned
this worldwide uh virtual school that's
kind of my dream and it might even have
physical incarnations but the physical
incarnations are just kind of places to
plug into this a worldwide kind of
school that spans all continents that's
that's kind of my dream
i have many so the question is have ever
thought of uh uh that i need to hire
someone to help me um the answer is yes
uh
i i have it's it's it's just you know
right now it's being funded by the
salman khan bank of america checking
account so it's uh
and and and they're pretty stingy so
so i i uh but i i i do want to hire
people especially on the software side
i've actually thought about bringing
other people for for the on the content
side even in english it's actually
harder than i thought i have a lot of
friends who would probably be brilliant
instructors but something about the
youtube format they start to freeze up i
think one of the big values about is
when i started making this i wasn't
getting paid to do it i wasn't it wasn't
like i wasn't stressed about like oh
this is for navi and armand well you
know they're going to take what i give
them so i literally like like i'm
answering the phone i'm talking to
teller marketers on some of these early
videos and and and and it has this very
like lo you hear my wife yelling at me
sometimes in the background i mean it's
really low-key but i think that's why
it's connected with people and and uh uh
uh but yeah but the answer is i would
like to hire up but a small team
probably five or ten people eventually
oh last question right there in the back
yeah so the question is have i ever uh
considered visiting the rural areas
where where the videos are being watched
firsthand uh the edge i i would love to
do that uh i have an irrational fear of
flying which i need to get over but
other than that um i i uh no i would
love to i it's it's uh uh i in
particular the group in uganda they seem
to be doing tremendous things they send
me pictures all of the time uh uh but
nothing would be more exciting than uh
than to do that and actually even my uh
my mother's village which is outside of
calcutta uh i i would love to they're
apparently using it on some level over
there as well uh so i would love to go
visit there and and see how it's been
used thank you very much